there you go hit the button on top turn
on the top guard user-friendliness
[Applause]
what's up everybody it's your boy Lance
freshman I'm here at my guy am I
Shumpert's house today we're gonna go to
the Magic Castle now they have a strict
dress code so Calvin Klein hooked us up
with some nice suits let's go you guys
what's going on da guy how you doing
good man you ready yes sir let's do it
yeah we're suit though yeah quite a few
hours it's a home bomb for no reason
mmm-hmm I usually wear gray look I'm a
great guy but let's do a color positive
feeling switching it up nice nice nice
throw some black pants on you deep
[Music]
all right how we feeling you always do
something that's a little pop this is
just more subtle I don't see how you
could lose with a suit like I said if
you if it's fitted correctly for you
like you can see what works what lays
right you know I'm saying but it's
always gonna be some sort of flair to
whatever I do so we go into the Magic
Castle so what do you expect like you
know what kind of magic are you into big
on like the car tricks people doing
stuff randomly just pulling the car down
my suit I think how the client has it's
pretty fresh man I think yeah ready for
this magic show yeah let's do Open
Sesame
oh wow it really works are you doing
Iman Lance I'm Joe Furlow good to see
you over the Magic Castle thanks for
having us we've been open since January
2nd of 1963 we host 32 magic shows per
night and it's a lot of fun
oh right hi everybody oh sweet video
card tricks are all about control I'm
gonna show you how this works all right
so for instance like I said sometimes I
take the three I put it right there in
the middle doesn't matter where it goes
it can go all the way on the bottom
dribble all the cards on top it's still
up on top that's what I'm saying like it
doesn't matter where it goes
cut off half the pack yeah all right now
put it back on put the cap put the put
the cover up there you go
hit the button on top turn on the top
card user-friendliness man you take it
good this is a pleasure
this is absolutely flashing there's
absolute pleasure